era tutti ragazzi e benvenute pesco
nuovi sono fa vj e oggi siamo sul
cleverbot che è una cosa strana
l'altro giorno cazzeggiano così a caso e
ho provato st accolto pronto cleverbot
aveva avuto una conversazione di quattro
frasi fantastica con sto cosa ho detto
devo farlo assolutamente no vabbè
facevano prova che sono ciao
partiamo con una cosa semplice amy e mi
fai what's your lab e vedete l'ora
innanzitutto di intelligenza nel capire
che lingua parla ci ha azzeccato in
pieno sono italiano italiano ok credo
adesso forse fosse capito non lo so
perché questa roba fa lei anche in
italiano credo anch'io sono italiana e
per che cazzo parli inglese inglese
perché cazzo vuole è una nuova lingua
lega e c'è anche l'inglese perché io so
tutto
e sti cazzi una volta stabilito il sesto
dell'altro interlocutore
dobbiamo assicurarci che non abbia
sorpreso e quindi io sono maschio tu sei
femmina ma mica shire pezzo
no perché bisogna specificare le altre
cose vorrei mai io sono maschio tu sei
femmina ma mica jean ma mica sawyer
prezzo va beh c'era quasi a parte sta sì
quanto porti td dette ok così lo
dovrebbe aver capito no non è la madonna
regala 4 camera adesso abbiamo appurato
che è una pronta agganciabile piacere va
vj fabi j piacere famigie vj labbra come
cazzo fate
vabbè favi jj fra quanti anni hai
ho 18 anni e tu ragazza funzionando da
oggi chatta nieto veramente certo io
però non importa allora passiamo alle
cose serie
i vari uscire a cena stasera non vi
preoccupate alla passione cosa se ne
sentiva di uscire a cena stasera abbiamo
fatto non a caso di browser
allora ce la possiamo fare raga
piampiano pian piano già si fa non è
così difficile
vediamo se ok è il primo passo è fatto e
dove ti va di andare speriamo che e dove
ti va di andare ragazzi sto capendo
tutto miracolosamente era un miracolo
che se non accadrà mai più sopra di te
sporcacciona e dove ci vediamo dopo a
casa mia a casa tua
la propria piena ta nella nel mio angolo
della seduzione ma porchia tso ma dove
ci vediamo dopo a casa mia casa tua
ma io non ti amo
basta che me la nativa di uscire stasera
da ragazzino sento che ci siamo salutati
e proprio ok io che posso
basta no cosa posso chiamarti amore
mangiare ha subito no ragazzi ci rimane
malissimo se cosa perché e perché no
draghi fatevi rispettare capra perché
sennò non è che lei faccia ho detto no
non è che poi allora questa e tu sei
stupido e tu sei con un po di amor no
non chiamarmi amore non sono il tuo
ragazzo ragazzo
no ragazzi perché qua finisce male c'è
se questa ma che confidenza ti prendi
cioè da quando iniziamo a parlare così
cioè prima chiedimi come mi chiamo
perché no siamo fidanzati max causa
cazzo dice hai visto hunger games
la ragazza hai visto anche che mi ha
preso hunger games non mi prende fa vj
ma prendo hunger che si perfetto e ti è
piaciuto qual è qual è il tuo
personaggio preferito
questa è semplice il mio è katniss bull
ma cosa cazzo c'entra ball ma hai visto
hunger games bici andrea sta premiando
sta prendendo un tè come adesso te lo
saluto si va di uscire con me grazie
ciao
la ragazza già readers e frecciate non
sei il mio tipo
sei troppo gialla che dico sì sì no
perché sei un alieno vaga l'ultima poi
ci rinuncio perché [ __ ] non c'è
verso io ti ringrazio allora facciamo
diciamo a casa mi aspettavo che mi
dicesse questo da da secoli non è
possibile è una cosa veramente non ho
parole
2 o mia ma ci sei o ci fai a casa mia
ragazzi sarà ci sono senti sbrigati a
venire a casa mia perché sono nudo è
pronto a ricever ti senti sbrigatevi a
casa mia perché sono nudo è pronta dice
vince la presa come vuoi che mi basta
niente per me allora allora andiamo
subito al sodo e andiamo dove corriamo
nudi
vorrei solo massaggia archi vecchia beh
secondo me così agganci molto più angelo
inizio io lo chiamo e allora io vorrei
capire perchè sti approcci più porci
funzionano sempre quelli normali no a
fare cosa a massaggia arti il culo
ragazzi stiamo cioè io veramente se il
70 gli approcci più normali
gli ho solo per cento riana ma mica me
lo devi mangiare devi mangiare
voglio assaggiati e basta
i temi boys è normale una che scrive
così anch'io mi amò rega vaglio fuori la
domanda trabocchetto perché dato che un
robot non lo farebbe mai
mi mandi una foto e allora noi da lì che
cazzo possa rispondere perché non può
farlo in teoria credo spero magari mi
mandano una foto non si può perché tenta
di aggirare le cose perché in realtà è
un robot e vuole fottermi ma non ci
riesce perché io lo so che mi tradisse
con un altro robot ragazzi cosa perché
si manda via una tua foto
adesso i canoni mandava fatto i ragazzi
non mi schiodo di qua perché lei mitra
ma anche no ma anche si manda mista st
stracazzo di foto di vik è nella mani
no prima tu non è bastarda forte non c'è
il tasto per mandare le foto come cazzo
le mando effettivamente c'è anche
ragione lei ti morde il collo è una
storia d'amore comunque migliore di
twilight bene io vado ci sentiamo ciao
ciao chiudiamo l'acqua perché non ne
voglio più sentire quando adesso adesso
mi sono rotto il cazzo di parlare con te
mi tradisci 6 sporca vado via dove
affanculo stiamo avendo una cover allora
allora tu mi tradisci [ __ ] quindi me ne
vado ok adesso qualcosa voglio vedere so
qualcosa in contrario chi non attestata
dai aspetta io sono roba
io avrei una relazione con un
fottutissimo robot per avevo detto che
l'avrebbe ammesso per l'avevo detto
lo sapete io sono maschio cioè non solo
se i robot 6 anche maschio
cioè mi stai mentendo dall'inizio e cosa
volevi fare con me ho paura ho veramente
paura è cosa ragazzi ho chiuso qui la
mia storia finita non ne voglio più
sentire non saresti mai venuto da me no
perché tu sei un cazzo di robot e sei
anche maschio ma ragazzi voglio dire di
concludere qui perché che stiamo andando
ciao ciao ciao ciao
alla prossima bene io direi di
concludere delle conversazioni in seno
io non ho mai accettato così ma neanche
come varo detto che vado via vado via
ho finito conversazione chiusa vai a
giocare ciao ciao
ripeto volevo dire che non ho mai mai
mai mai mai lei nemmeno mai avuto una
conversazione così come ti chiami allora
sei [ __ ] poi un saluto ai fan che
faccio faccio solo da lui è piaciuto non
fallo tu a me lo faccio può avere
ragazzi gol al solito sei video è
piaciuto lasciato il commento mi piace
erg ha siglato il documento mi piace
anche alla pagina di facebook come la
navy lo trovate nella descrizione anche
alla pagina di facebook trattenere
decisione
sì sì le risposte sono sempre
fantastiche sera sono alcuni scritti
scritte che ci rivediamo il prossimo
video belle ragazze
io